hello and welcome to the agenda let's
take a look at what's happening at the
second plenary of the month
ong tsuchi is an icon tsuchi was awarded
the sakurao prize back in 1990 for her
personal struggle to help bring
democracy to burma
imprisoned in her own house for 15 years
by the military junta tsuchi never left
her beloved burma for fear of permanent
exile the woman who may one day make
president take center stage on tuesday
at the plenary as she finally receives
her award
now following on the back of hip
replacement and breast implant scandals
it's time to get tough
medical devices whether an implant or a
prosthetic limb or in vitro devices such
as hiv and dna tests will have to pass
stricter quality checks meps will vote
to adopt measures that will see better
training better regulation and better
control on tuesday
ninety percent of decommissioned ships
end up as scrap on south asian beaches
because ship owners find it too
expensive to dismantle them in europe
reform is underway to incentivize
environmental ship breaking in europe
and to allow ships to be broken up in
developing countries but only if the
facilities are clean
mep's vote to adopt the draft report on
thursday
trafficking money laundering violence
and intimidation organized crime poses a
big security challenge
3600 criminal outfits operate in europe
new legislation aims to stop them by
targeting their business their money and
monitor our external borders to stop
criminals getting in
meps give their formal approval to the
crime money laundering and corruption
report on tuesday and that's all we have
for this agenda take care and enjoy the
week